I tried working for somebody when it's
very young and they fired me and I
scream right and it was a very very
profoundly affected me profoundly and I
just said I'm never working for anybody
again it doesn't mean your life is
easier in fact you give up you have to
have a lot of sacrifices in on the road
to success and a lot of failures along
the way I just find it a more
interesting way to spend your time and I
really believe in this concept of money
buys freedom and so you know I think
it's a very noble pursuit for some
percentage of the people out there but
not for everybody because you have to
sacrifice a lot for the period that
you're working on your business and not
everybody wants to do that and I think
you find that in your own you start down
that path and if it's too much of a
sacrifice you revert back to being an
employee which it's very noble to do
that to but it's not the same thing it
takes a long time to set yourself free
working for somebody else I was with a
bunch of other investors who I respect
and they brought me a deal and I wanted
to be part of it but it didn't feel
right and I wrote millions of dollars on
that one and it just didn't feel right
and I lost it all within two years
absolutely and trust you this is a
barometer of risk it's something an
internalized for an investor that says I
don't feel comfortable it's not about
emotions just don't write that check
that was recently the first time I
didn't listen to that and I lost
everything so now my radar is up I
listen to my gut it's not an emotion
it's an index of risk and you get it as
you age you become a better investor
every year if only I could live to 200
I'd be really good you just watched two
amazing clips from Kevin O'Leary
take the next three minutes to sit
quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]